hey guys welcome back to the corridor
digital podcast you might have been
wondering where those guys go I didn't
know that they made videos until they
made a podcast and told me about their
videos yeah well here we are we've been
here the whole time just in this room
you might notice we have a new set up
that's because we got the node computers
here everyone said in the node in the
node channel they were like hey guys can
you sit on the couches I feel like it
would be better vibes if you sit on the
couch it better vibes yeah a little so
here we are yeah three couches three
dudes three mics
I've got Nico and Sam here with me today
this is the group I often refer to as
the Triforce when in conversation with
ivy wow yeah we have wisdom power power
and courage Constitution I don't know
perception check okay guys we're gonna
do a new thing today on the podcast the
first thing we're gonna do and the only
thing we're gonna do is talk about well
we might talk about more topics but
we're gonna try to keep it to one topic
so with that it's 20/20 I mean 20/20
where does the time go
it's a new decade yeah I know 10 years
ago we are we lads and now look at us
we're just standing tall men normal lad
with families yeah as of 2020 we are all
dads yeah yeah so oddly enough are also
the only dads in the corridor but it
makes sense it trickles down topic we
talk about dad economics no stop it we
talk about corridor in 2020 and what
we're going to be expecting yeah I just
kind of wanted to talk I mean cuz we
always go through this thing every year
and we always talk about like well you
know we go over the company and we talk
about well what did we do last year that
worked what did we do what do we want to
do this year oh boy last year what a
year based on that so I kind of just
wanted to like take people through that
conversation that we have mhm and I
think people will get it get a little
bit of more of an insight yeah on what
we do well then in that case I do need
to put
disclosure that everything we say on
this podcast is not guaranteed to happen
yes yeah that being said hopefully it
gives you guys some some insight and
hopefully some things to look forward to
yeah right so twenty nineteen twenty
nine this is how we always start this
conversation 2019
what happened how'd it go was it a
successor because every year at the
beginning of the year I don't know if
you guys do this but I always write down
what success means for that year hmm and
then I put it on my little wall over
there next to my next to my desk
why'd you write for 2019 well I wrote I
mean I can pull it up yeah yeah I don't
do this this is uh yeah this is a long
term like pay off tradition that you go
for here let me get it let me get it
I'll be right back
that's cool that's a really interesting
way to organize your thoughts it's like
it's like the opposite of New Year's
resolutions it's like last year's news
predictions predict or yeah yeah last
year I predicted this would happen and
then you find out if it came true or not
which is the most revealing part and
then you after you got to ask yourself
well if it didn't come true why and if
it did come true why yeah let me just
you say this is a really tradition night
this is my first time hearing adam lyons
actually taught this to me yeah yeah in
like 2015 he had a when he was living in
Oxnard mm-hmm he had a little like Adam
Lyons's Avengers meeting like all of his
buddies and he was like okay guys so
this is what we're going to do this year
I want you to mark down let's see and so
2019 here we go right here
let's see 2019 success corridor YouTube
channel first things first I wanted to
make 25 videos on corridor yeah oh boy
we did not we did not accomplish
like seven or eight yeah so so the
question which I always ask myself is
why why did you not accomplish this and
the first the reason I put is that we
spent more time on the corridor crew
Channel hmm
we sacrificed the time to spend on those
25 videos and we spend them on the
corridor crew channel which I meant a
lot of time on that yeah we did that but
also a lot of the videos we ended up
working on were longer endeavors I mean
obviously the Boston Dynamics we did two
of those videos last year right it
sounds crazy to say because the first
one feels forever ago but each one of
those videos took weeks to the point of
you know if we did 25 videos of that
scale it would have been impossible
you had rotating teams working three
hour three shifts a day yeah so then the
next thing on corridor YouTube was I
wanted to release two videos a month
same thing as the first you know same
answer I wanted to do five brand
integrations we did not accomplish this
why did we not accomplish this my reason
the industry landscape has changed the
integrations landscape has changed but I
think is on the corridor Channel
Squarespace ads no yeah that's that's
that's great okay how many videos do you
think we did do last year I think we did
just off the top your heads you saying
does the pogo stick and everything
counts okay every upload every upload on
the quarter channel public that's right
guys it's a private quarter channel that
only we it was innovated 14 I was gonna
say 14 actually you guys both guess
pretty good the answer is 17 really yeah
well like you may be 18 if you count our
battlefield commercial announcement
video but she got this here well those
rush videos name is not last again yeah
surprisingly actually we got a lot
closer to this than I thought yeah I
should point out too we got more views
last year than ever before yes so that
was the next part is six million subs I
didn't have a view marker but six many
subs we far surpassed that yeah we got
seven last year wait we've got up to
seven yeah we passed seven as you say
for those of you who are just listening
I have my phone
I'm double-checking all of these
analytics while JK shots him out
yeah rats 1.3 and then I wanted to try
for experimental episodes hmm so I think
we hit this because we did boss Town 1
and 2 yeah we did pogo we did pogo stick
we did the Keanu deep fake mm-hmm and we
also did the oh that I think breed is
more because he could count top 10 games
he can play in your head as
environmental you know you could carry
it ii primatech video as experimental
though in every video is an experiment
yeah but yeah that's true i guess i just
meant like like rush up till 3
technically was an experiment but the
first one might have been no then so
that was corridor and then i just go
through i at corridor corridor crew okay
mom 100 videos we think we did that did
we did a hundred and six or something
Wow
to videos ambitious we hit that nice 35
brand integrations we hit that Wow
actually we did better than that
two million subs did we we definitely
hit that hit that mattress actually game
two million subs like I see here on top
of like the ones already had and single
topic episodes which was the big thing
that we were talking about at the end of
2018 remember yeah really
let's stop doing these too if you guys
remember if you guys have been watching
since 2018 you'll remember the vlogs
used to be everything are they being
yeah I was we had a stories we had B
stories we had ceased or --'tis it was a
flip around between all three all two of
them
yeah and then we and then we realized
hey wait a minute people watch these
videos more if we release them as single
topics and so that's what we started
doing yeah yeah um so again if you guys
are like hey I miss the old vlogs just
think about it this way we listen to
what the audience says effectively in
the sense that like we noticed that when
we put out single topic videos they
would get almost double the views and
it's like well there's a reason for that
it means that more people want to
watch those videos mhm and it means that
your payoff from the thumbnail to the
expose of the piece this is better and
so more people are watching it now you
might like the flip flop you know
between just what's going on every day
in the office but there's a clearly a
larger majority of people that liked it
the other way so that's why we did it
yeah that's not to say that you can't
have you know your own tastes or want
your own things which we also
acknowledge and like that's just a part
of us figuring out how do you balance
like if you have something that caters
to a smaller number of people who are
passionate about it and yet something
that caters to a bigger number of people
is their way to balance that that's one
of the things we want to figure out
going into 2020 here actually that's
every year yeah yes that's every year
you're right yeah we got some plans for
that which we'll talk we can you'll find
out more about that as time so did I
finish this or should I move on to my
2020 plan no no finish this okay all
right I'm just you know I'm just thrown
a couple tangents just give context we
have the corridor cast that was on my
2019 success list 50 episodes we did not
accomplish that you are not the father
why we D prioritize the podcast that's
that's hard truth man that's the honest
truth yeah I'm glad we're doing it I'm
glad we're doing this episode but at the
same time we had to recognize like hey
there's a niche audience that likes this
show so let's just make it for them and
for us yeah I mean there's there's a big
I guess elephant in the room is to like
why all these things got deprioritized
and that is visual effects artists react
oh yeah you know it's yeah that blew up
caught us by surprise to a certain
extent and then it became you know
question of can we do that consistently
and it at high quality and then maintain
the rest of our creative output I think
we did to some extent it just happened
slower you know yeah I had to find the
balance right and then we we also
shifted the rest of the format on the
crew Channel we shifted the rest of the
focus of the company to accommodate for
that explosion in viewership yeah I mean
we went 10x in viewership
mm-hmm
almost let's straight up yeah yeah so
that's it's not like you sit around and
plan and you're like okay one day when
we go ten eggs and viewership say how
you gonna do that so yeah it's just no
it's just gonna happen when it does
we'll be ready it's like no you we had
it we had our way of doing things and
then came in and it was like oh people
really liked this show we should
probably make it a priority yeah so yeah
it's kind of weave out we do we do that
every year there's sort of like sort of
like a hierarchy of needs of content
needs you know and each year they shift
and move around and yeah well I think it
speaks to the team strengths that we
were able to adapt and start making that
show and honestly improve on what it was
when it first came out even and still
keep everything else going you know and
still have really great corridor videos
dropping you know the podcast Wilson his
frequent bird dropping the podcast and
you know having the in-between corridor
crew videos that weren't VFX react
having those still be really strong
videos as well right so yeah it's you
need good people for that but it takes
time to build that takes yeah years yeah
yeah well honestly that the VFX artists
react show really changed
I think the studio more than anything
we've done since like starting the
channels to be honest well there's also
a subtle like it happened at the same
time which was subtle but and it falls
behind like the shadows invaded VFX
artists but that's you know the shift
from Carmichael to Dean Nick and Matt
yeah yeah that's for sure yeah it's
definitely a big transition point there
Carmichael was in labor for three years
he pushed out the baby that is VFX
artists react and he put it in the
basket and lifted other horses getting
me shifted down and the Dean found it on
the side of the river garments yeah for
real I mean it's really there's so much
we can say about it but I think I mean
obviously this show is super successful
and it's really great seeing like all
the new viewers but more than anything
else you know as kind of like artists in
the quote-unquote industry
it's been really really cool to see
people reaching out about the show and
you know we've been doing visual effects
on YouTube and doing all these videos
and stuff and then suddenly now last
year we have people you know from like
way to like hitting us up another
filmmakers feeling and like people who
are in the industry doing similar things
now finally going oh like hey look at
these guys this is cool they're doing it
and it's not necessarily because of even
the quality of our videos or anything
but just simply because we haven't had
anything come out that was so
personality based like seeing you know
you and ran and Clinton and myself like
us as personalities out there for people
to see who's making this stuff and
there's just an incredible amount of
reach that that show had that has kind
of had a really positive ripple effect
through everything we do yeah so I just
it's pretty cool I mean because we've
been working for that for like many
years already at this point and we kind
of in 2018 where we're kind of like oh
well I guess we're just our own little
like satellite here you want to do
another thing and now suddenly it's like
oh no like everyone kind of sees what
we're doing which is really cool yeah
that's one of those things like as an
artist that makes you happy makes you
very happy you know it's like having
this life passion intersect with
suddenly everybody else is passionate
like sharing the same thing and you know
getting to these these people you really
look up to in the industry and having
them reach out to you and hey you know
watch your videos in the office or we
talked about this hey I worked on this
shot here's how we actually did it and
they're not you know reaching out to you
and they like you you lied about me you
know how I missed a shot up like this is
really why they reach out to you really
enjoying the episode you know I saw you
guys broke this down you know here's how
we actually did it and you know it's
just it's super positive and ya know
it's very very fulfilling having you
know those are the people we look up to
in the industry reaching out and like
saying that they enjoy our work you know
so it's nice to do something positive on
YouTube too that gets views and read
something that's controversial you're
trying to whip up a mob yeah
make a rant it's like yeah let's all be
angry yeah look angry angry let's just
get outraged it's nice it's nice to make
content that gets views because people
are interested in and that it has a and
that it's positive and even when we're
even when you guys are critiquing the
bad VFX there's a reason for it
mm-hmm it's like well they missed this
obvious thing that could have been done
and so it's still constructive criticism
in a way yeah all the replicants from
the challenges that no one's been able
to solve yet yeah and say here's their
attempt at how they do it yeah yeah so
2020 so that's 2019 mm-hmm and 20 yeah
now 2020 are you ready for these goals
boys all right what's here all right
corridor crew 125 videos Wow okay that's
more than for those of you listening who
do not know how many weeks they're on a
year that's more than two videos a week
for the entire year I think we can get
to three videos per week by mid-year if
our patreon hangouts count we might
really hit it yeah and and and also I
think there's still there's still
there's still a need from the audience I
think are like a demand from the
audience to want to watch more stuff
that's happening in the studio and I
feel like we're giving them that but
we're not we're just we're not quite you
know these more updates constant updates
like here once a month you get to see
and as to what's happening in the studio
I was like well cool it's just like two
weeks out of the out of the month you
release three instead of two mm-hmm and
then you hit that yeah which is kind of
what we're doing and if we do more
corridor videos which we'll get to then
then I feel like that'll that'll happen
five million subs on-quarter crew yeah
okay
see we can hit that where's it at right
now it's at 3.2 it just allowed last
week Wow good for us I'm just you know
doesn't matter it's all neutral we
should talk about note in a minute here
- yeah we have a lot of horses we do
then corridor I don't have a number on
here but
because we're still kind of having that
conversation but filmmaking for what we
have tentpole ideas that drive public
viewership and those two are the sort of
the main fronts like what what are this
some of the what are some of the boss
town asked if it videos that we're gonna
do those tentpole videos that are gonna
drive people that where it spills the
bounds of the regular audience it even
spills the bounds of the YouTube
audience mm-hmm and it gets into the
greater public so that people now are
they're like oh hey oh you do those
you're those filmmakers ya got to do a
couple of those I mean just making more
boss sound videos in general it would be
great because like that's just the
concept that I mean well we have to
figure out how to make it a little
easier to make them but but but even
still it's just like it clicks yeah I
think people you can go in anywhere that
idea still yeah are we gonna do roller
blades roller blades we can't do
anything on wheels unfortunately oh
you're right because the the tool the
suit doesn't works on wheels you have to
be planted with your feet so any
technological restrictions it makes
sense do you think about it but like if
you tell like you know something like 30
years ago about a mill cap suit and like
look it works great just can't have
wheels I think we should do like like
service industry stuff where it's like
trying to bring food out from a kitchen
to a table full of like unruly guests
and it's like trying to hold these like
platters of stuff well what if it's like
a mob it's like the month the mob is
having dinner and it brings it out and
it's like doesn't know and they're like
you can go now and it's like and the
robots like yeah I said you could go
what what's with this [ __ ] robot
it's just saw Wally get to do robot out
of here but they're actors cuz it's like
it's a simulation it's a testing
environment still yeah for the
spider-man show at Disney World by the
way No so they need spider-man to do
things that a person can't do that's
super dangerous such as like get
launched by a robe like 100 feet day or
do you like three flips and then like
all my hands I've seen this stuff
so they're building robots their base
that basically do that they look like a
human being and they move like a human
being so they can just launch this robot
into the air and it'll move like
spider-man wait and they're just
designed to do this one that's all
they're designed for whoa yeah this
video of it yeah this is the early like
development they're learning how to like
make something move like a human being
all in the air whoa and though there's
land on a net you know that's a dang
robot for those of you listening
Cristiano spool my gosh
footage of a robot that is basically
since it's gonna be spider-man trapeze
flying oh my god yeah just like the most
intense Cirque du Soleil Acrobat so that
someone would probably kill themselves
that biffed it they just have a robot do
it yeah you should look up this Disney
robot stunts because basically it's like
throwing a Boston Dynamics robot into
the air and having it do a million flips
if it is cool if a human doesn't do it
things the kids aren't gonna know the
difference and I feel like a lot of
people in general will notice the
difference because the way they'll set
it up theatrically you'll probably miss
the moment where they transition from
the real person to the the robotic
double-o definitely will yeah that's
crazy I mean I guess it just makes it
more entertaining at the end of the day
everyone wins you know yeah you saw
those except for those other man stunt
performers yeah except performers who
came up from the Vagabond trains of
Europe my father was a Spider Man stuff
before me and my grandfather and now
robots gonna take my damn job yeah and
all the spider-man stunt performers are
gonna be out of work live-action
spider-verse the seven spider-man stunt
performers okay moving on I also put we
wanted to do 50 videos on the podcast
this year because I think we can break
these into episodes and last but not
least we have node every node now we
have this little no this is a crying
little baby our air some node so hard by
corridor yeah in the core
four of last year yep yep we put another
channel under our wing yeah yeah and
well someone will do a full story on
node.js actually we're gonna do that
probably the week after next yeah yeah
so we'll have that both that on the node
channel and I'll probably talk around
the podcast too but long story short
node is now part of like this the
corridor umbrella so we can bring a lot
of our resources to bear on it which
means that you know not only will we
have video game videos and of course I
like the airsoft videos and things that
no it's kind of known for but we need to
bring to the table a little bit more
production quality and more of the
resources that we have here at corridor
2 ideally make these games even more
robust and you know executed with cool
costumes and cool props and you know
just getting out into doing interesting
scenarios more often yeah and also you
know the videos we did last year in the
year before on on the crew Channel
mm-hmm that were you know now that we're
now looking back on it we're like oh
yeah like that was fun to do but it
definitely doesn't fit in like the nerf
games and the things like that like
there's like a huge element of
creativity we wanted to do with the crew
channel that now we can combine with
node
yeah I'm just super cool though the
biggest thing like when it comes to node
is that you know when it comes to view
game channels especially with us like
we're not the best video game players in
the world and no one really cares how
fast our head shots I was like man
nickel can shoot head shot so fast
like you know like the only game we were
legitimately like world class that was
Splinter Cell blacklist yes and it was
great and we were yeah we were the best
in the world top the top players but
other than that no other game had that
expectation and I feel like it was very
difficult to make really compelling
content with games you hop into
basically for the first time and you're
like oh gosh like dude what button is
shoot yeah so a lot of what we're going
to do this year with our with node is
focused on bringing back like fun
experiences which really is kind of what
the channel was in his very first year
like the original land parties it was
like a bunch of friends getting together
in playing a game and having a fun time
and like we really want to de-emphasize
playing like the newest cutting-edge
game and we really want to
re-emphasized you know us friends are
getting together playing a game and
having a good time and that might mean
playing old games like rocket League or
playing Smash Brothers or playing you
know the original Goldeneye or something
like that but as long as it gets us like
jumping around and screaming and like
yelling at each other like that's cool
and that's what I want to do you know
four note in 2020 yeah we're starting
that well we've already started that
mm-hmm
yeah some of the content that you guys
have seen since we started bringing in
the crew
yeah the halo video the AI dungeon video
but we're doing an AI dungeon video just
gonna come out the same days this really
funny by the way it's sorry yeah for
this the story starts off as a spy story
I mean super hero flies off with someone
else's wife feather alert Chicago gets
destroyed that's why I like a a dungeon
is because it's bizarre blend of gaming
and like podcast and like it's got some
of the D&D sensibilities there but yes
it's it's pretty cool because it's
always going to surprise you
yeah and gave us some amazing
illustrations and yeah that's a huge
part of it yeah and then we're doing a
video well actually this could be part
of a whole series this would be the
first one it's could you survive is the
current working title but we're doing
could you survive a bad attack a bat bat
no like a baseball bat oh can you
survive attack attack yeah yeah so that
yeah I feel like the live-action stuff
too is gonna hit on that more and more
of this some like a lot of the stuff we
used to do on the crew channel that we
can't really do over there anymore
because it's so focused on like
filmmaking and yeah and visual effects
and like you know all the stuff that we
kind of set out to make the channel
about but that's why it's so great now I
get for it where it's like perfect
because now we've we kind of have these
horses and all these horses are like
they all have different stats and Mike
you know he's fast horse got this app
like this but he has a lot of HP HP
that's the corridor channel high
Constitution this horse an older horse
but he's ripped through channel super
super fast
we got node which is kind of like this
like it's like one of those show horses
that prances it's like a wizard channel
I feel like but a wizard magical horse
no I'm a unicorn no no no not a unicorn
more like be like I suppose like a
reindeer okay I can go with dancing
horse I think I was prancing show horse
you know you know prancing it's been
doing this for four hours along the
parade route and it's just like god damn
it and then then then the what is it the
podcast it's like a little horse that
Minnie Minnie it's a smaller horse and
keeping your stable but the thing is
it's that it's the horse that is in the
stable at your home and you and you can
go out there and ride it whenever you
want yes you're not like trot you're not
like you're not doing anything fancy
with it it's not cutting its major
comfort horse yeah it's it's whatever
it's gold you just want to ride along
the sunsets when you just ride your
local trails with it you know
yeah what's the guillotine channel the
guillotine channel the engine Broncos
hop on oh I got this in the kicks you
off and you're like wow we left it in a
field somewhere it's still out there
wild mustang got a good hit on her head
from now and now there's a rumor
spreading like whoever can whoever can
tame the Bronco go out there yeah cool
so plans for 2020 yes we're going to
rethink the businesses horse analogies
no I think we just we're gonna have
custom painted horses put next to
everyone's desk and each person is gonna
get to customize their own horse
painting yeah so yeah I think that's
actually really it'd be really good for
morale yeah yeah I think so
everyone gets their own unique horse I
want a brand an Appaloosa horse with
like black socks and a
you know black is this guy dropping
horse terminal yeah this goes my
daughter's really into horses that's
learned I think I'd do like a fjord like
kind of they're they're kind of their
kind of stocky but they're really furry
you know they're from Norway you know
and anemia they got a lot of hair what
kind of course would you pick what would
look we got to pick at least or just
tell us what it looks like yeah maybe at
least you gotta have a favorite color
horse a race horse the horse I'd pick a
black boy I don't know quite a serious
black steed this one's a hand like that
almost like that oak Brown like but like
with dark hair yeah yeah black classic
black hair just a bound bound brown
horse black hair
yeah no saddle you don't ride with
saddle just put a black Mustang there we
go no I don't know I think we settled a
Mustang they named the car after cuz
it's cool yeah makes perfect yeah
alright next thing there's two other
things to talk about for 2020 first
thing is this website that's a big
announcement are we coming in this
podcast well it's plenty funny I mean if
you guys are watching the podcast or
listening to it it means that you're one
of the congratulations guys you're one
of the 1% that's true if you're losing
this podcast we know we know that you
are truly your quarter challenge we know
your fruits are true crouton the city
WTF a love croutons but the thing is
actually this is this is like really
high level stuff this is like in inner
circle okay we're about to drop some
inspiration circles yeah so we're about
to drop a website that's gonna host our
videos and also in time allow us to
develop
entire series on that site for that site
for you so if you support us on patreon
at the $5 tier on right now or before
February 1st you're gonna be entered
into a beta launch of this site where we
want you guys to go on there watch the
videos play around with it break it tell
us what's wrong with it isn't it you
want to hit all the buttons as fast as
possible the idea behind this site is
that if it's it's our place we can
distribute stuff that people want to see
that might not necessarily work on
YouTube and of course everything we've
ever done on YouTube without ads mm-hmm
because we realized over the course of
all these years like hey that's a great
idea
not for YouTube that's a great idea not
for you - how many times have you said
that a million million times countless
of times every day I wake up in the
middle of nights cold sweats yeah that's
a great idea yeah I go that's a great
idea life wakes up and goes not for
YouTube she's like that's not yeah half
of the time it's because it's a bad idea
the other half of the time it's
legitimately because it's not for
YouTube but this is what I mean about
the whole like postmodern cinema post
post cinema content post cinema content
that yeah like which we'll get into in a
different eye because listen to this
post cinema topic when I get posted is
there's there's all this stuff that
YouTube is a great ecosystem for certain
kinds of videos certain kinds of stories
and I'm not just talking about like oh
well we need more money to do this
no I'm talking about like it's good for
certain stuff but not for everything
like it the way that the algorithm works
the way that the ecosystem works the way
that the audience works well YouTube
doesn't value a person as much as say
Netflix does right the amount of revenue
that you as a user generate for YouTube
is not as high as the revenue that you
Netflix generates from your subscription
and so if you if we want to make content
that you value highly the only way you
can be a valued user is through a site
where you can have direct you know
connection to the material that's being
made for you whereas on YouTube you're
just literally your view your view is
where
money is worth eighth thousand of a
penny yeah something like now so no
something like that so yeah actually it
is so with this this is different
because now your viewership is worth way
more to us not only because we're not
losing money to YouTube who's paying out
money to themselves as for creating this
incredible website but also because now
your per person they're contributing
more than point zero whatever point four
penny percent that's going now into the
end of the content yeah and so we're
gonna start with the patreon beta launch
which is gonna be at the $5 tier so go
to patreon.com/scishow or digital you
guys aren't patrons and sign up for the
$5 tier before February 1st and you'll
be automatically entered into the beta
launch of this site using the same email
that you signed up for with patreon and
that's the secret right now no one else
at that $5 tier they don't know this yet
right we haven't even told the patrons
yet we don't know if you're a patron and
you're listening to this we're telling
you right now yeah this is yeah and
we're actually well we're gonna I was
gonna announce it to him I know I will
announce it but yeah either way it's
still yeah it's pretty cool but but it's
yeah sorry continue oh and then after
that we're gonna test it with this
select group of people and then we will
launch the actual launch and when the
actual public launch happens then
there's gonna be like a 399 for people
that weren't in the original patreon
beta and that's just gonna be the
standard like membership for the site
but what the patrons are gonna get is
like an additional point system that's
gonna allow them to contribute a little
bit more per project that they'd like us
to develop yeah we're gonna do on the
site is create a but is effectively a
point system where you guys tell us what
you want us to make in a way as in we
put out a couple ideas we're like hey we
could bring back the vlog we could do a
D&D show supported with live action like
cutaways we could do
the what is the this man stuck in a
self-driving I mean some narrative
concept narrative concept but multum
Italy it's it's imagine like Netflix and
you hearing all the announcements that
are coming up for potential shows
they're making and then being able to
like basically submit a token yeah to
these projects based off of what you
really want to see ya at the membership
you'll occur more points and and you can
continue to contribute those yes
projects and then the difference here is
that like you know previously on patreon
we kind of did a similar thing we when
we started our patreon page we actually
had some tears that were like here's
some like videos we want to make but
from a creative standpoint a lot of
things didn't work out there because we
kind of were getting ahead of ourselves
with you know the youtubes changing
ecosystem and with this we're
approaching a little bit differently in
the sense that these these projects that
will be on this side are things that are
actually actively in development and
we're intending to make but actually
being able to make them kind of yeah is
played into your actual decision on how
you use the site when you ever site like
I see our subscription that subscription
has this value and now you could
actually say like hey I want you to put
this value that I bring towards this
thing and that allows you know let's the
vlogs have a smaller audience than the
FX RS react do for example but this
allows the people who want to see vlogs
to collectively say like we want to see
this here's our points we're putting it
towards this and now boom it gets made
right like this is a way for you to
actually take this power into your hands
to get things produce that you want to
see and it's a way for us to put things
out there that we can make and then ask
you guys what do you want to see you
know you get you get a point a month or
whatever I've you know having we even
worked out the points yeah so as Sam
said earlier no ya don't ya don't know
let's do it
but this to the exact points the concept
is you know you get a point a month and
this project takes X number of points
and so you know you throw them at them
and other people are thrown their points
out the thing once a month and then boom
you hit it and then the thing gets made
but if you want to help us figure out
the point system that's what the bait is
gonna be yeah for yep yes we're gonna
start we're
start figuring out the math of like okay
well the average people who are watching
now who our members now are watching for
about this much they're watching about
these many videos a month and then we
can average that out because the main
thing that we have to figure out is cost
because on it when you're launching a
site that has video streaming the
highest cost is the bandwidth cost
because video data is the more data than
any other form of data that's basically
on the internet other than video games
and so you have to figure out how much
that's costing you and then once you
figure out exactly we have somebody we
have an idea but once we figure out
exactly sort of what the averages are
the more information we collect the more
accurately we'll be able to predict it
and then you can say like okay well
caught each person say it's a four that
we expect them to come in at four
dollars well we're gonna spend a dollar
and a half or we're gonna spend two
bucks on the cost to provide them the
service and then now if they get X
amount of points and they choose so that
now they're bringing that extra two
dollars that we can put towards the show
mmm-hmm right so now how do you convert
that into points and then how do you
give people the opportunity to utilize
those points like across a slate of
shows that we're comfortable producing
for the amount of points that it's going
to cost exactly and what's even cooler
is that you know when you look at this
if we're running our own site here and
you know hosting the content there it's
already a niche audience in a way like
when you look at our YouTube videos and
the style of stuff we're creating like
there's there's always in the back of
your head it's like how do we get this
to the most viewers rather than do
something that like us and a part of our
niche an each part of our audience so I
don't want I say niche because it kind
of it's it's not really the right way to
say it but like the part of our audience
that really connects with what we're
doing in like a more fundamental level
and and so having this website it's
basically a way for us to kind of go go
right to you guys who are who are super
passionate about a certain style of
content that we're making and and
communicate that in a much more direct
way with us and gives us that
opportunity as well to
kind of make that stuff that a lot of
people really want to see but doesn't
also make the most sense to post on
YouTube right just because of the whole
economics of the situation there yeah
and then the idea is you know we start
small we start with some earnest stuff
that we can honestly make for you guys
and and then we just try to grow it from
there and yeah we're people that are
signed up the bigger crazier stuff we
can make I'm just gonna have a giant
public launch with like a big like
venture capitalist funded guys are you
ready to light that to million dollar
money pile on fire okay we expect it to
last about nine we expect the fire to
last about nine months if you guys
aren't into venture capitalism there's
actually a term in venture capitalism
called your burn rate your burn rate is
literally refers to the amount of money
that you burn through before your
company actually starts to make money
now obviously there's a utility all this
cause like you need venture capitalism
for a number of different things but
like how many times have we seen
especially over the last it's not so as
common now but especially it's like
three years ago between 2013 and 2017
how many people came in and were like
alright we're gonna do s bawd it was
like yeah duh of course they'd go 90 of
course vessel vessel yeah yep what else
is there everyone was doing whatever
people were you're involved with but
yeah those were the big things now I'm
sure it's like okay then why are you
guys doing it making videos yeah it's
like we're not like starting from
scratch here we work or we're creating
something else that pairs with what
we're doing we're also we're also not
trying to make it bigger than what the
audience wants it to be which is the
first mistake that I think a lot of
those companies made it was like well we
got to get a hundred thousand
subscribers in order for this website to
be viable right now with the people on
patreon alone the website will pay for
itself good job good job everybody we
did that means now if we want to host
and create additional content for the
site
we just need to make sure that the
people that are signed up for the site
cover the cost that it costs to make the
content and to run the site and if that
grows then the website grows we're not
going oh whoa we're gonna burn we're
gonna have a burn rate about $100,000 a
week until we get to a point of
profitability which is a recipe for
failure often times I mean there's
cirthree there's some people that are
professionals at this and they do it
with stunning success but yeah not I'm
not that smart I'm not gonna die and I'm
not gonna try to pretend that I am that
lifestyle is too fast for me it is man
it's too hot too hot too fast yeah it's
too high and burning too quickly
I watched a documentary recently called
a magic not magic gadget general magic
it's talking about this company that was
basically you know they saw they
envisioned the iPhone before the iPhone
was ever a thing basically they just had
you know a competitor like you know the
Newton or the you know palm like pocket
or whatever remember the Newton back in
the 90s and you know the thing that they
had it's like you know they win for
everything in one right away and they
just hit the market hard and then no one
bought it cuz no one wanted it and they
crashed hard versus had they mean this
is what they say you know had they
iterated and done something little by
little they would have came out come out
with something that would have
eventually work because you don't run a
business by putting all your eggs into
one basket and going boom it worked or
maybe it didn't and now we're all
screwed well a lot of people do a lot of
people do good you know well that's how
you have most businesses fail yeah but
that's not how I do things here court or
yeah yep so you know we're hoping that
this process is something where we all
get to grow together and we get to make
content that people want to see and it's
a direct relationship between the P
between all of you guys and what you
enjoy singing what you want to see and
what you're not getting from anyone else
out there and what we can now do for you
that's right so if you guys want to get
in on that you want to get on the janky
pre public launch version of the site
that we're still gonna be messin I don't
with him don't worry if you go on there
and it's
it'll be fixed momentarily for a couple
months pretty slick so far actually I'm
under playing it the compression is way
better than YouTube really we have the
video quality Christian just pull it up
oh wait can we get compressed through
YouTube anyway so who knows it's true
it's not gonna work they don't do it's
ready I didn't show it so we good it's
still cooking right so anyway yeah we'll
announce what the site URL is and how to
get on it in the upcoming patreon
livestream there you go
this month yep January 31st yep
that's when I'm gonna schedule it
January 31st Wow what are you here yeah
we've got no channel to turn him to us
amazing camaraderie and everything horse
yes this amazing prancing horse that
will live for prancing forever and ever
people will come from miles to see its
prancing the amazing prancing horse
question dancers we have quarter crew
which is this dashing horse that's
setting records left and right that now
is a good solid year of solid racing
ahead of it to just win some trophies
everyone knows this horse's name now yes
we have Corey over sitting in the
background somewhere doesn't ready to
like stop on the tries to get too close
to it yes quite the mighty steed don't
know hurry I'm gonna make anymore
guillotine video so that Mustang might
be lost in the woods if we had more
studio space we could make more yeah we
I would definitely be down to make more
guillotine videos but that's another it
only takes like what how many seconds
for that blade to fall like you shoot
tons of videos and hopefully hopefully
your comfort horse at home okay the
podcasts will be riding together more
often that's right together try to do
this weekly though I was we were
supposed to film three episodes and we'd
ended up just talking for an hour about
one this is like corridor and 2020 and
darks
action on 2019 yes don't expect every
episode to be an hour I actually think
they're a little bit more fun if they're
shorter even if we give ourselves time
constraints actually want to try that
yeah you guys want to see that let us
know Jake that's the thing with this
horse though it's in your yard you go
out you ride it for an hour right for
ten minutes yeah you know you know who
knows screamin kids and the wife is
nagging you to clean the dishes don't
you go out on a horse ride and you see a
storm coming you're like I'm gonna turn
around who knows but it's always there
it's always there as you can for five
minutes and then yeah yeah see how far I
can get you just go out we'll get a
little pet give it a carrot you know who
knows so what do we have to look forward
to I think we should do that little
premiere for direct before the podcast
people listen to this or now what do you
have to look forward to the next couple
weeks here on the podcast well we're
gonna do weekly videos that that I can
almost promise you right but discussion
topics yes and then we've we've got a
couple interesting topics you know we
like to talk about like technology and
AI and stuff so Nico on the next one's
gonna be talking about machine learning
yes that's right and how machine
learning can revolutionize the visual
effects industry and surprisingly why is
not why is it not happening already
because it's all you sitting there for
people to do stuff with Wow so I can't
wait to talk about that and what I can
enable now you may have heard of
post-modernism but an episode three
we're gonna be talking about postmodern
cinema no no there is postmodern cinema
Oh
post cinema right there is already this
modern cinema that's an entire genre
that was a mistake are we talking about
post cinema content or is implying that
cinema has changed yes post cinema I
love it and then what goes horses
monkeys words I didn't want to have a
discussion about kids content on YouTube
because it everybody's you know of
course anytime YouTube does something
people make outrage videos about it now
people are apparently
outraged that kids videos are getting
demonetised earlier they're about rage
they were monetized but you know what I
think we can take a long hard look at
well personally I think it's kind of
weird to make videos with your kids and
monetize it as your source of living
when your kids have no say and whether
or not they're gonna be on camera well
that is a great topic we could talk
about that easily for an hour because
what it has to do with more
fundamentally is it has to do with how
how fundamentally we think we can
restrict a parent's right to determine
the way of living that they want to have
with their family it's a really tricky
subject it is if you think back in the
day born on a farm there get out there
and plow that field I think a really
good example though is that like a lot
of kids television oh boy I'm getting
into it no no yeah it's a hefty topic
with a lot of things and not to mention
on the legislature that's just been
going through yeah it's I think it's a
it's an interesting topic that's all
affects us now directly but it's a
there's a lot of history that points to
like and a lot of precedent I would say
with how it's been handled in the past
mm-hmm that shines a really good light
on the direction forward for how much
yes because yeah all they're already
laws in TV and filmmaking for how you
handle children's content and children
on set not to mention the child's data
all right some more on that and other
topics related to film technology and
just are random meanderings
boy next on the corridor podcast thanks
for being here and consider subscribing